good evening good evening
good evening and welcome to this Central
planning committee meeting of Malden
District Council on Thursday the 19th no
we're not 19th of October we're the 16th
of November
well yeah quite uh 2022. uh I am
councilman Carly Mays chairman of this
committee this meeting will be streamed
live and recorded by being present in
the meeting you are giving consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please indicate if you wish to speak I
will then invite you to do so the
appropriate time
I encourage all members to keep
contributions clear and as concise as
possible when invited to speak please
remain seated and speak clearly
remembering to turn your microphone on
and off appropriately
when speaking and referring to agenda
papers
please ensure that you reference a page
or paragraph number
uh for those at home the officers um
present tonight are miss Catherine
Matthews and Mr Michael Johnson and our
Clark is uh Miss bird
uh apologies for absence Miss bird
thank you chairman apologies
thank you thank you
um we now move to item three
um and it is recommended that the
minutes of the meeting of the central
area planning committee held on the 19th
of October that's the correct date 2022
are approved as a true and accurate
record these are presented for accuracy
only ISO move do I have a seconder
thank you
can these be agreed by a cent
[Music]
item four Declarations of Interest
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda have
in regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B
of the code of conduct for members
members are also reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise through the meetings
do I have any declarations
none no no declarations Tara
item five application
2200820 Promenade Park Park Drive Malden
found on pages 11 to 32. The Proposal is
for the use of of defined areas of the
Promenade park for concessions in
temporary structures such as gazebos
tents Shepherd's Huts or small motorized
vehicles to support seasonal attractions
between April and October exclu
inclusive and between the hours of 10
a.m and 10 P.M
the application has come before us as
the applicant is modern District Council
and it is and it relates to land owned
by the council
furthermore councilor councilor Swain
the ward member has also called this in
under policies N1 and N3
Tara can you remind me should we hear
the speaker first or should we hear the
presentation first
chairman the presentation first let me
hear the speakers thank you
um Miss uh Miss Matthews um please could
you present your report that was
circulated to members yesterday thank
you
all right and thank you chairman good
evening members so as um the chairman
has said this application was deferred
at the last central air planning
committee to provide an opportunity for
the applicant
to um provide further information
regarding the proposal
so I can quickly run through the
presentation which is the same as as
last time so this this plan identifies
the seven areas of the prom Promenade
Park which are subject to the
application
a block plan showing the same seven
areas
outlined in red
again the seven areas identify slightly
closer
you some examples of the temporary
structures that have been at the park
um and that used would is what's
proposed to continue
some mem site photographs so they've
been labeled a to f
and then we've got
um some photos there relate to that
that key
um and those short members are as
familiar with the park as as I am so um
in terms of the further information
that's provided in support the proposal
um the and and in response to some of
the issues that were raised
um
during the debate at the last committee
and which are also in your in your
agenda so I'm only repeating what's in
there and in terms of the management
plan for the the park
um the
um as as is referred to in the Malden
and haybridge Central area master plan
the the production of this plan is some
way off 2023 at the earliest and so
officers will suggest that it would not
be appropriate or um the two postponed
consideration or determination of the
current application and for that plan to
be in place first
um and it's been explained the demand
for these types of concessions and
continues post pandemic the council is
seeking permission to continue allowing
similar concessions to operate from the
park beyond the permitted development
rights which exists which is a maximum
of 28 days per year
to provide the council with the
flexibility to accommodate a wide
variety of concessions within a choice
for locations in the park and ensure
that no opportunities are to enhance the
provision of facilities in the park are
missed for the 500 000 plus visitors per
annum the site subject to the current
application all Sites which have been
accommodated concessions in the past and
it's not anticipated that all of the
sites would be occupied at the same time
a maximum three or four is anticipated
or that they would be occupied for the
whole six-month period apply for or even
for their the hours the maximum hours
are proposed the council's landowner
will control the number and type of
concessions allowed within the park and
it will be in the council's interest to
ensure that the park remains an
attractive visitor destination
the application will allow the council
to ensure the site maintains its
popularity can respond to emerging
Trends and ultimately stay competitive
so that businesses can benefit alongside
visitors looking to enjoy their day out
this application is designed to enable
the council to appropriately manage the
park aligned with current corporate and
Commercial objectives and provide
capacity for future management plans you
know in um in the councils the
applicant's opinion the application
you're looking to formalize the existing
previous established arrangements and to
enable opportunities
um into enable opportunities rather than
deputize aspects that attract users to
users of the park
so
um as as was recommended previously
um officers recommend that planning
permission is granted but subject to
conditions including a temporary three
years
maybe on hours
um limitation to October to April to
October only and for no more than four
of the seven locations to be in use at
any one time details of refuse refuse
storage and Disposal details of tree
protection details of a flood warning
and evacuation plan and also the
ecological related conditions which have
been recommended by
um the ecologists and consult a
um thank you
thank you
um we have a public participant for this
planning application and in line with
the public participation scheme I now
invite them to read out their submission
um
Mr butcher
you have uh I may remind you that you
are allocated two minutes only for the
public speaking in accordance with the
with this scheme your time starts when
we put the clock on the board
brilliant thank you Tara
oh
no sorry it was uh Catherine thank you
Catherine
you may start when you're ready thank
you chair good evening members um I just
wanted to attend tonight to give some
additional context as to why this
planning application has come forward
for clarity this isn't about hosting a
range of semi-permanent structures on
all the locations you see on the map
um it's going to be something that's far
more likely to be one or two per summer
season
um the application has come about as a
direct result of covid and I don't know
if you remember during the restrictions
we had periods of time when families and
friends could could only mix together
outside
and to support this this mixing and to
support local businesses planning laws
relaxed to support the businesses to
trade outside
it was during this time that the council
was approached and had a request for a
temporary bar to be located in the park
this wasn't something that had
previously been considered
um but by officers for a period of
longer than 28 days prior to covid
however now the planning laws are back
in place we may on occasion wish to
support local businesses in in our parks
and opens or improm park for a period of
longer than 28 days and hence why this
planning application has come forward
it's incredibly unlikely that would have
it any more than one or two temporary
structures at any one time and and for
most of the time we won't have any
um but we want to identify a number of
areas to avoid repeatedly coming back to
committee when opportunities arise
I think in further support of this
application I think uh what this does uh
help facilitate as well with these
semi-permanent structures is to be able
to put things like electrics in place so
that we can have the facility to perhaps
remove diesel operated ice cream bands
and have something that's electrical
electric operated
semi-permanent concession
um but without without this um this
planning application approved that that
may not be likely we'll have to rely on
things that that can come and go on a on
a 24-hour basis
um that was all I really wanted to say
uh chair thank you for the time and um
yeah thanks
thank you
thank you Mr butcher
members I'm now going to open the floor
to debate
um and I'll start with um
councilor none
uh yes thank you chair um it doesn't
take a lot to confuse me uh nowadays at
my my time of life but
um first of all I'm a bit confused that
Mr butcher is here talking through the
public participation scheme uh albeit a
very well informed member of the general
public rather than as an officer
um but you know so be it uh the second
area of confusion that I have is that
last time this came to us we sent this
back
uh asking for a more clear a clearer
more detailed plan of direction for the
Promenade
and we're being told that that plan is
some way off we've been waiting a long
while for that plan but we're told that
it's due in 2023 which actually is what
a couple of months away yeah but it
depends depends when in 2023 I would
have thought that at the very least we
could have had some kind of interim plan
of Direction but it's a shame we haven't
got that
um I've read through the amended report
and it doesn't look an awful lot
different to me apart from the ecology
that Miss Matthews has mentioned at 1.2
and a bit of clarity at 1.3
but
I think that the the thing for me is are
we actually saying that these
Arrangements were made under temporary
powers
for permitted development under 20 for
28 days but are we simply saying this
committee needs to decide on those
existing arrangements for a more
permanent period of time or are we
giving carte blanche approval to
officers to introduce any concessions
that they want thank you very much
chairman
my understanding is that this is is to
allow the continuation of
the use of the park for concessions that
had had
started during covid and was permitted
didn't need Plantation during covid
because of those the extra measures that
the government or the temporary
emergency government introduced allowing
um some extra development to be carried
on without needing plan permission so
it's it's to continue that and and I
think the the the the
pandemic has
um opened council's eyes I suppose to a
certain extent to the opportunities that
do exist and and it and introduced
interest in the park commercial interest
in the part that maybe wasn't there
before the pandemic but it is it is to
continue essentially what has been going
on and for the last two or so years
um
but but but but now the rules have
changed so permission is now required so
that's why the applications has needed
now when then it wasn't
um in the last couple of years when when
the rules were were different
if that helps
thank you chair I I think that
clarification is helpful but I'm still
wondering whether this is purely to
confirm existing and previous
concessions or to allow carte blanche
approval for any future concessions
Miss Matthews Do you have a
a view
I have a view
the um
the the the application is typically the
the application is to
provide Choice as as said before and um
and it these site all these sites have
been used in the past for this type of
use
um but this is that the application is
to formalize that and and allow that
that to continue in in the future with
with the but with the the council as the
landowner
um assessing and
um
and um and and and allowing certain
concessions to operate from from these
sites
um but my understanding is that the not
all the concessions have been asked to
go on the site have been allowed to go
on the site because they felt that they
weren't the right
um the right ones for the park and um
but that that process that vetting
process will would continue
um even with the planning permission in
place if that was I don't want to hog
this chest I'll leave it for now thank
you
uh councilor Lagoon
thank you chair there's um there's a
couple of points uh I'd um I'd say I
don't believe that all Sites have been
used before from my recognition there's
some some of the sites have been used
before not all of them
the sites were used concessions have
been on the prom before covered Grape
and Grain as an example
um but there's just a couple of points
um I'm not against concessions on the
prom which some people might fall over
um but I think that they need to be done
in a very measured and very planned and
very careful way
um if you go back to the reason why we
deferred the meeting the actual wording
says the chairman proposed that the
application be deferred to come back
with a further information on the part
management plan with a well thought out
strategy for the development
that's this is what's come back is not
that
I would agree with you cancer alagan
thank you chair
um and I think it's very very important
to also pick up again what councilman
said and I picked up what you said chair
about it's actually a 1.3 page 12. the
the report says the publication of a
management plan for the Promenade Park
the park referred to Modern Sanctuary
master plan Camp is somewhere off 2023
at the earliest 2023 six weeks and four
days yeah and I know we can it might be
pushed back to there
um project 16 in the camp was passed in
2016. it was I think it was supposed to
be delivered last year actually yeah
there's and it's been it's been spoken
about and spoken about and spoken about
that that hasn't been delivered so I
can't really see that we can go ahead
with this
until we get
the wealth without strategy for the
development we've now got the concession
strategy which is a good document and a
good thing which we can leverage off
and I think what we need to do is
wait until that plan is developed
because nothing's happened in Winter
um from a council perspective we we get
four weeks and then winter comes and we
basically sort of shut down
so there is electrical work going on in
the prom
um there is electrical points being put
down there because I go down there twice
a day
um also on page 22.53 which I believe
was for a modern Town Council with a
reason to refuse I think that's a very
strong reason to refuse this as as it
stands at this moment in time
um which is the reasons that modern
District Council and Council Swain
called it in on
um and and also on 7.3 which talks about
um the uh
points in the report of 5.3 it's design
and impact on character of the area
5.3.1 and 5.3.2 5.3.2 actually says it
knows that good design is fundamental
for to high quality new development that
they're not with no disrespect to any
business they're not high quality
development I go back to what Mr
Salisbury did on the Promenade
irrespective of my own personal feeling
about a town asset it's a lovely asset
to the town
I don't think these really nail it so I
think we need to be a little bit careful
could you put the um images back up on
the screen for members just to remind
themselves what is being you know
arranged yeah sure proposals and chair I
just thought members to sit and look at
it and go
you're talking about Malden's Promenade
Park
okay that's great we've got markets
we've got I've got Army days we've got
all of those things but sticking
something on there because zebos for six
months of the year really doesn't I
don't think it fits in with the
fundamental strategy of the park and
therefore I would would say that in this
this proposal be rejected
um and I I feel I can't support it as it
stands because of those reasons we
haven't got what we wanted we've got six
weeks before 2023 comes up we should
look at doing something in the New Year
we should push for even an interim
management plan where we can actually
get some involvement in it and then talk
about what's needed on there look at the
commercial leverage that we want um it's
a win-win situation for the businesses
and also don't forget we've got to think
about the residents of the district
we're talking about all the people
coming in but what about the people that
use it every day in the winter time as
well
so they're just points I think I'd like
members to consider
thank you
councilor Swain thank you chair
um yes I the reason I called it in in
the first place last time was so that
there could be some discussion of the um
proposal not that I had any
um
reason particularly personally one way
or the other that stage
there are a number of points um that
have cropped up first of all this
um elusive from part management plan
um I I can't I don't know when that will
emerge and I think um we can't
um sort of hang around if something is
dependent on that it could be next year
it may not
um and uh
to to make that a prerequisite I think
is is
um
unworkable
um I can see these valid points about
um wanting to uh having planning
permission which would enable the use of
sites Beyond a 28-day
um
um quite reasonable and obviously it's
um worthwhile from the the applicant's
point of view
um
and I note in there in the text
somewhere that they they're really the
objective is complementary
activities to those existing in the park
um
which does come back to the question of
using um
Petra or diesel driven Motors and I I
think um no
um well I want to come to two amendments
we haven't even got a proposal on the
table
sorry we haven't even got a proposal on
the table at the moment no I will I will
propose those in a couple of seconds
um so I as they are sites in the
air within the area that um
um
is uh of obviously usable and right for
um
visitor
um not attractions but for visitor
support should we say
um I think that's quite quite fair
enough and I would accept that well I am
concerned about this question in um
uh 5.7.7 about Harris fencing having to
be used
um to protect trees I I would hate to
see that stuff
um
around any of the locations
um and also
um about the where the restoration of
this of site of concession site areas
the area the end of the
end of the lake area which is very which
is very well used I don't see any
possibility of that being
um restored to its original estate
unfortunately so the two two
recommendations or for conditions that I
would like to propose
um are that concessions will not use
Council Spain if you could hold on just
for a moment with the concessions
um and and the conditions
um we haven't got a proposal either way
at the moment
so these would be amendments to the uh I
understand conditions yeah can I come
back to you
um once we've had a little bit more
debate
um on on the other aspects
yeah uh Mr Mr Johnson thank you chairman
just to just to point out um obviously
well aware of is having read the report
um this is a temporary permission in the
first instance
condition one relates to
um the application uh uh site being
restored back to its original permission
uh position condition within three years
yep so this is a this is not a permanent
permission at this stage this is
effectively a three-year permission also
uh conditions attached
um is that of the seven identified
locations only four at Max would be used
at any one point in time
this is for basically half the year
which has been which has been proposed
for so these just need to be born in
consideration
when as members have it as part of their
consideration the lack of a management
plan
um from a planning point of view that's
not an issue we're dealing with here
we're dealing with effectively a
temporary permission at this point in
time for a limited number of spaces
amongst a number which can be chosen
from
um
of what I would add in as well for
members consideration because there's
been discussion around the the type of
structures there
from officer's point of view it's we
have examples of what could be put there
there may be variations upon that but
just to say if members felt that
um the type or design I mean I
personally don't have any idea that the
type or design is something that needs
consideration there could be a condition
that before any structures are put in
place a more detailed type of design or
or specification or range of
specification is something that would
need to be submitted before structures
go in place so I'm just sort of putting
that out as part of the consideration
thank you chairman thank you
um I'll go to councilor spensely uh and
then cancel a bill
thank you chair
um so going back to page 12 and 1.3 and
I I take on board Mr Johnson's advice
there that the lack of a management plan
isn't a material planning consideration
but then I think that begs another
question for me because as you know I'm
a relatively recently elected member and
I'm discovering a lot as I go along and
one of the things that I'm discovering
is that I'm puzzled about a few things
so exam for example here we have this at
1.3
about the management plan I find it
absolutely extraordinary that this
Council doesn't have a management plan
for Promenade Park I'm sure there is a
whole plethora of reasons and and
um you know words that one could use to
explain how we've got to this point but
correct me if I'm wrong the prom's been
there for quite a while so I'm quite um
I'm quite astounded by this not only
that but it occurs to me that this has
come forward as a planning application
which is actually to be quite honest
um puts us in the position of not being
able to really take into account that
there's no management plan so here we go
again because I'm going to say that as a
member and this is I've got to be
careful how I say this I'm beginning to
feel more and more that members are
being excluded from a process in terms
of looking at you know our contribution
it's almost as though
this is bit Happening Now by accident
we've got conditions here which talk
about an ecological strategy and how
people are going to escape from flooding
so all these strategies if we had a
management plan correct me if I'm
understanding this wrong would already
be there so now what it feels like a
little bit to me is we're kind of
getting a management plan by osmosis
we're going through planning and we're
we're going to do it that way and that
way we're we've kind of got a bit of a
gun to our head here haven't we because
we know that there are popular
concessions there and we know the
pandemic highlighted this opportunity
with all due respect I'm really curious
as to why these kinds of opportunities
never occurred to anybody ever before
and I'm I'm really feeling now very torn
because I have complete empathy with
businesses that are there and know how
popular they are and I'm worried about
what what it will mean tonight if we if
we refuse this application and I agree
with councilor Swain that it seems to me
that holding off for a management plan
now seems as though it might it might
not happen but I'm also at a loss to
understand why it's not actually there
and I do think it's unfortunate that
we've had the officer speakers at public
participants tonight because it would
have been nice to have an opportunity to
maybe ask some questions
because I I I I you know I'm sorry but
for me as a new member this is quite
disappointing to be brutally honest
thank you chair thank you
councilor Beale
yeah thanks for Nick in one of my uh
uh it was that but then if you go to
5.3.2 it says uh
it's basically the creation of high
quality buildings permission should be
refused for development of poor design
and I presume we're going to um monitor
what these Caravans look like before we
give permission are we I don't think so
why are we looking at seven plots when
you're saying in your report that
there's only ever going to be four
maximum
why are we considered even considering
this without a plan which we've just
been discussing I mean it can't be too
late to leave this till next next year
when there is a management plan in so
we've crossed the t's and Dot the eyes
is this just another MDC or we need to
make some more money
I mean
um
we've already been told as well within
the chat there that that basically this
is for three years for like temporary
permission but are we saying that if if
we're only using four out of the seven
at any one time I can't understand why
we're using seven
and only allocating four the other thing
as well is
if someone drops out
who is it then down to to replace them
is it the officer saying oh well we've
got a space vacant now
we need to whatever
vet these people to see if it's
something that we want you know who's
going to manage the change
once they've got permission
I think we ought to be waiting until
we've got a management plan in place so
at least we can cross the T stock the
eyes and I think we're all legal and
above board then but to me this is it's
just a half cut idea
you know to even put in there then it
needs to be good design
can you imagine that top left Caravan
turning up how's that going to improve
the area well it did
um I I don't disagree with you at all
councilor Beal
um my own comments I'll come to you just
a moment uh my own comments are on on
the design we don't know how big they
are we don't know the scale we don't
know proportions uh we don't know Mass
all of these things seem to have been
ignored in this planning application
whereas we would be insisting in them on
them in any other application from any
other
um uh uh applicant
um I am very disappointed
um I had hoped that this application
wouldn't come back to committee quite so
quickly it's been a month
um and would have actually been much
more substantial in its offering and in
its diet design uh perspective and it
hasn't and I am like others
um hugely disappointed I'm going to go
to counselor stilt and then I'm going to
go back to
um councilor Lagann
stilts thank you madam chair
um
I'm a bit confused
um like everybody here I as you say I
would like to have seen some some
drawings
um and some plans of what these
temporary structures would have looked
like rather than being Caravans and
gazebos
but the other thing that confuses me is
that the officer mentioned that this if
we pass this application it would allow
them to put electrics in
um there's no mention of electrics on
this plan at all
and if you go to the flood risk and
drainage on 5.6
.2 it actually says there will be one
stall above the flood level during each
of these designed flood events so does
that mean that the electrics would all
be underwater
because that there is nothing in this
plan that talks about where these
electrics would go how they would be
cited
and what conditions would be put on them
in the event of a flooding
well that's my comment
okay thank you chairman
um just um perhaps have an opportunity
to respond to
um some of the
um comments hopefully you'd be helpful
um
so in terms of waiting for next year
obviously there's there's no timetable
for production of a prom plan
um so as cancer as the chairman
suggested it could it could be early
next year but
it could also be the end of next year in
which case that would be quite a long
time to wait and I also understand there
is
um I don't know the internet but I do
understand there's some pressure to
um
um some need to get a decision on on
this application
um sooner rather than later so that
plans can be made for the park for next
year
um that's um that's what I've been told
um I think the other point I'd like to
make is that um
I understand it it's difficult but um
this is a planning application and um
it's a planning committee and I think
some of the issues that have been raised
are more appropriate for the council as
a landowner rather than the counselor
it's a local planning Authority
um and um and I'll perfectly understand
the the concerns of of members but
them there there is the there are other
committees by which the the management
of the park and the vetting process of
the of the um the people who would or
they um the users of these sites would
be would go through
um and um
there is that a sort of Extra Protection
if you like that the council as a
landowner will be will be making
decisions about who goes where and and
for how long and if it's not working out
then they'll cancel the landowner can
decide not to continue with it
um because I've just come in there
um I think the point that I'd like to
make is that
um whilst I don't uh not agree with you
I agree with everything that you've said
however if we're looking at this as a
planning application which we should be
and I think we are
um we need to take into account what it
looks like what the damage is going to
be visually as well as physically
um we need to look at what the effect
will be on the existing businesses there
we have to take into we have to take
into account a whole I mean you know
I've got a list here proposals upon the
enjoyment of the area the appearance of
the surrounding area and upon highway
safety
um I just feel that none of these things
nothing has actually been considered at
all there is nothing that holds together
any of these sites so we're not saying
that all all the sites are all going to
have
um are going to be color coordinated
they're going to be made of a certain
type of material they are going to be
you know so all our for example all our
gazebos let's just take Zebo so we can
put gazebos everywhere they are all
going to be dark green
um or they're all going to be white well
I think they're white ones in in that
particular one or we're going to allow
any color gazebo is that what we want to
see across our Park
um in I can't remember the number but
the Harris fencing around trees do we
want to see Harris fencing around the
trees during us at the summer months I
would suggest not
I hate Harris fencing this is a
Victorian Park no consideration in my
view anywhere in this application has
been given to that that fact
nothing at all
I don't know I don't know yeah yeah okay
um I don't know in specific references
that Harris fencing I don't think that
necessarily has that's not what
um has to
um be installed I mean there's there's
lots of ways of protecting trees Harris
fencing is is is one of them but that's
um but there are a lot there are other
ways of doing it and as Ms Johnson has
said in terms of what these concessions
are going to look like it's perfectly
within um the council's powers are
planning authority to impose a condition
requiring that details are made
available and arrow agreed before
um the the development um
um carries
um is carried out so that there are
there are controls there
um that the uh that could be put in
place through the planning system to to
um yeah to retain the control and
perhaps hopefully that would allay
concerns about what what these
concessions are going to look like um
and these are only examples so if there
are some if that such a condition is
imposed and these examples are um not
acceptable to to members then then they
can be excluded through through that
process
um so so you're suggesting that we uh
that we uh rubber stamp this and then
use conditioning in order to uh ensure
that everything is uh suitable for a
Victorian Park
that is that that that that power is
exists yet to um but we were only
supposed to use conditions
um
they are not supposed to be in there for
that purpose I didn't think that was
what they were for condition no covering
what what what a development looks like
is is perfectly reasonable and and
um there is a material planning
consideration what what development
looks like so and conditions for example
the you know if permission is given for
a house then it's perfectly reasonable
to ask for samples and materials so that
we I will detail further details of
Windows um so design and appearance is
is covered by conditions
um every day almost every application
has got a condition on
um
um that relates to something to do with
design and appearance
um so yes that is perfectly
um within a crap in the within powers
and um and and not unreasonable so um
yeah so in terms of
um I think kind of eventually you've
said about would like
um
an officer here to answer questions
um I think in response to that said well
there is always the opportunity and I
always encourage members to ask
questions about things
um before the committee uh if and if
members do have questions that they
would like added at committee then
please let us know in advance and
answers can be can be provided it is
very difficult during committee at
committee to have answers for questions
with that are not anticipated
um and in terms of
um uh the the officer who's here being
here as he's here as as the applicant
and and we thought it would be unfair if
he was hearing any capacity for other
applicants who can't come along and
answer questions and almost join in
joining the debate
um so um the new the other I them
thought I had or comment I was going to
make is that if the lack of a prom plan
is of particular concern to members of
it sounds like it is
um again going back to the conditions
that have been recommended I'm
recommending a three-year period
so by the end of that period even with a
considerable delay in the in production
of a plan there should be a plan in
place by then and then at that time the
The Proposal could be reviewed in light
of the plan and if it felt that it did
not fit in with the plan or the country
to plan in any way then obviously the
members would have the power to reassess
and reconsider it at that time and the
three-year temporary period will also
give the council as a local plan
Authority an opportunity to
um uh see how the development was being
carried out and if there are issues or
concerns raised then again that would be
an opportunity to review the decision to
be made
um maybe not necessarily to refuse
permission but maybe extra conditions
could be then considered and imposed so
that three-year period would also give
say an opportunity reviewing of
um and testing the water I mean that's
often how temporary permissions are are
given
um just to see how things go and if if
things aren't going well then you've got
an opportunity to say no or or
impose different conditions or come to
come to a different decision in in some
shape or form I think so
um I'd like to go back to members I'm
going to go to uh Council hubner then
councilor Beale and then counselor
um spenceley
and then
councilor Swain and then Council
councilor Lagoon
um councilor hubner
thank you chair yeah I'm disappointed
because
um we've had we're talking the same
language as we did the last time
because they aren't
I was looking at the minutes and you
know nothing was put in there and no
answers have been given to us to bring
this back to the this committee so
um that's what disappoints me we're just
talking the same
thing there's no Heritage strategy
there's nothing thank you uh councilor
bill
I'll tell you what else
it's not very often I say I'm speechless
but I'm still going to talk because I've
got I just cannot believe that this has
even come before us a second time the
Clue's in the title who's the applicant
Malden District Council who's the
planning Authority Malden District
Council
if anyone else out of the Malden
District Council put an application in
like this without so much information
not being given it wouldn't even see the
time of day
why are we even considering this this
should this should be deferred whatever
you want to do refused and then it comes
back to us when we've got a management
plan when we know when we show that we
know what we're talking about
and and as I said the change in design I
mean if we want that we'll just invite
the local circus in
you know that's that is not protecting
our heritage as Council and none will
probably say you know for the
conservation area and everything else
and down the prom is it was it Victorian
isn't it yeah yeah Victorian and a
getting stuff like that it shouldn't
this shouldn't even be considered the
fact that there's so much information is
not there and it's disappointing that it
is actually the planning Authority is
actually trying to get something like
this through
Joe public wouldn't
thank you I mean I'm fuming I
love it okay thank you
um
councilor spenceley
yes I just wanted to come back on the
assertion that we should just read this
and have asked questions days before I
think we asked questions at the last
committee so I think actually I'm not
sure what question I should have asked
the lack of a master plan is the lack of
a master plan and with regard to having
an officer here to answer questions I
wasn't expecting Miss Matthews or Mr
Johnson to be able to answer questions
around why we haven't got a master plan
because as Mr Johnson said it's not
really a planning issue and that was
part of my point I feel as though we're
doing this without the background that
we should maybe have had from elsewhere
so I I you know I just have to make that
point because I feel that we did ask for
more we did and and I understand that
you know it seems to be not fair and
therefore to to let our officers speak
on this because it's a modern District
Council application but it's so tied up
with what we what we want to ask
questions about outside the planning
consideration operations that it's
difficult because the information isn't
in here that there isn't a lot of
information in here to to guide us as to
what's trying to be what you're trying
to achieve and I think that's the issue
but anyway I'm I'm not sure this came to
the right committee first I'm still not
sure of that thank you chair thank you
um councilor Swain
yes thank you chair
um there's um obviously a lot of points
being made which aren't relevant to this
planning application which is simply
really simply to allow these Severance
sites to be used on this slightly
different basis to what they would be
currently
um and just and the
the question of the Promenade Park
management plan is a bit of a red
herring because if and when that is
produced
um that will
um uh govern the way
um operations are conducted in the in
the park and Council Swain just for
clarity a management plan for the prom
Park would include all of the aspects
that we have been talking about this
evening that are some of which are
covered under planning some of which
aren't just so you know what is included
in a management plan for a prom yes well
that's a different issue
um
um and that's this question about design
we're talking about temporary structures
you can't apply the same kind of
um disciplines and and conditions that
you would if you were talking about
determine structure
um and uh the the that there's a purely
operational issues which fall outside
this application and that's how these
sites might be used it's nothing to do
with whether they are able to use them
um so I I there's a lot of irrelevance
there
um as to um the
the environment of the park I I would
remind members that Queen Victoria died
120 Young years ago
um and times have changed and the way
the park is used and the kinds of
population that use the park and want to
use the park and the kinds of
um interests that people have now to
that bring them to the park from a much
wider area than they ever did in 1900 or
1910 are so fundamentally different
um so I the the one aspect of the
Victorian Edwardian era that I would
suggest is relevant is this question of
is the question of quiet enjoyment but
that comes down to the nature of the
concessions
and activities that take place on the
park and that falls outside the planning
area that would come under the
management plan or other management I
think actually noise and that sort of
thing does come under under planning and
is considered under planning so no so I
I see this as fairly Limited in
in its impact
as a purely planning issue the others
fall outside it and will be swept up in
due course and either in terms of
um performance and governance or in
terms of the management plan if and when
it emerges and
I'd like to come back to the two okay um
we need to I'm going to go to council
Lagann
um we need to actually start to draw
this debate to some sort of conclusion
um
I've already taken another comeback but
I haven't from uh councilor stilts
unless a unless counselor I'm sure
honestly you wanted to speak
um at all
thank you
a plan a management plan is sorely
needed thank you Jeff thank you all
right I'm going to go to um councilor
Lagoon thank you chair I'm not going to
labor the points because there's been a
very good debate this evening and I
think just to pick up a couple of
questions made a couple of points that
are correct
um but the the prompt like he said
there's a red herring for this in the
report so it does have validity for
debate tonight about the management plan
um and you're right it has changed an
awful lot but quite contemplation and
lack of over development and not trying
to fleece everybody out of as much money
as they can get when they take their
families down there has to be considered
because it's a very important aspect the
points I wanted to make can I just ask a
question can you put Planet plan
information in for a year
so where this is for three is could you
do it for a year
thank you chairman um yes you can have
uh we brought temporary permissions for
a year two years
any period that we think is appropriate
and reasonable
okay thank you thank you the other
points are uh you've still got the 28
day rule haven't we in place yes so we
can still we still put so we're not
limiting people to come there
um
consider why this is way off the title
and you can tell me off chair but
consider why I've put all these motions
about trying to get member involvement
onto the Promenade Park management
this is a prime example that you're
right the officers make decisions they
make them under delegated powers that's
within the Constitution and that's the
way it is at the moment
um it's never come forward to members
um we've never been asked although we've
been offered
um that but that's not happened and the
final thing that does worry me and I
know Miss Matthews has said that yeah we
don't have to use Harris fencing it's
about the trees the trees are in put
most of the trees down the primer
planted in memory of Malden's Fallen
that worries me greatly that we don't
get this right and this is the reason
why I'm proposing we reject this
application on Balkan scale or over
development
um because I feel that if is it six
months if if if this is supported uh is
it six months before an application can
come back
I don't know Mr Johnson
thank you chairman
um well an application can come back as
soon as an application's in a position
to come back okay well therefore there's
not a time limit on an application
coming back right well I therefore I put
the proposal to the committee that we
refuse it
are based on over development out of
keeping and basically everything that
Morgan Town Council said
foreign
so is that on um design scale design
scale bulk in keeping with the
environment Outlook
detrimental to the overall enjoyment of
the park for which it is there uh Mr
Johnson I think Outlook is they're all
supposed to clarify chairman uh I think
it'd be uh
difficult
um to uh give a reason for refusal based
on design and bulk and scale where we
don't have a detailed design just almost
like an outline application where we
give approval to the principles but then
subject to the detail yeah that's almost
a scenario that's created when you have
a permission like this and you have
conditions designing you know detailing
that
you must submit detailed plans
um before anything can happen if that
doesn't happen the condition can be
refused yeah because I did actually want
to make a point about about conditions
um there's a number of conditions yeah
but yeah this is an additional condition
if it was an additional condition around
desire no structures to be uh in place
until
um you know designers submitted showing
size type that sort of stuff yeah
um
if the local planning authorities are
unhappy with it uh it's refused
um in the same way that any other
applications refused I'd have to go back
to the drawing board and come back to us
so there's that measure of control
um
uh while not common it's not uncommon
for some uh uh
conditions application to come to
Committee in some authorities yep that's
not an uncommon thing although it's not
very common uh because these are
normally matters that are meant to be
just dealt with in in like uh 28 days if
I remember I can't remember
um so I would be concerned about reasons
for refusal based around that here
[Music]
um
there's been discussions around the the
management plan from a planning point of
view we have we have a time period which
is six months yeah
um these are temporary structures they
will be removed after six months it's a
temporary planning permission in terms
of how long that that six month per year
can be applied
as we've discussed members can vary that
if they want yeah they can have it a
year you might say well we're not happy
we feel that a year should be enough for
us to at least be able to see something
and to see whether there's a production
of a management plan while the
management plan is not a planning issue
that may be a council issue yeah so
that's not something I I or Miss
Matthews can get involved in the
discussion around that yeah so there's a
there's a lot of control you can put
over that if you're not happy
um we feel can I just come back because
they give me lots of reasons why we
shouldn't turn it down and absolutely
nothing why we should although I forget
the feeling in the chamberries that we
are not happy with it and we're looking
for a way to try and say at this moment
in time this is not right but we're not
throwing the baby out with the bath
water so what could and from a member to
a professional officer what could be the
reasons based on the conversation you've
heard tonight that we could put a
proposal for us to turn it down in this
current form
uh to be unfair to ask me that position
uh because that's that's not how my
thinking is about this application I I
feel that the application can be
supported I feel that
it can be supported even if it's not in
the form that members have in front of
them yeah uh by by changing the
conditions around the time period
and those sorts of flexibilities that
for me is within the scope where there
can be some control and some management
exercises yeah and
it's within members give to that that is
quite reasonable to do if you want it
just for a year it can be a year yeah
officers can't argue against that yeah
you know there was a discussion last
time around the seven sites
um uh one of the things we put to the
applicant was that seven sites I say all
at once would be uh something difficult
for me for members to consider so it was
then brought down to to four but four
within the seven but only at any one
point in time
um so there is scope within that but I I
can't say to you why this would be
refused because I don't think that it's
in a position to be refused on what we
have in front which is a temporary
permission
um with any additional conditions okay
thank you chairman thank you Mr Johnson
the it
I'm sorry
okay what's your point of order point of
order is we as members we should not be
asking the applicant to come up for
reasons why it should be turned down or
whatever what sort of nonsense is that
people have tried it before and they and
they say to the planning officer
what reasons can we give it's not down
to the planning app a planning managers
councilor stilts
cancer Stout sorry thank you
um as for these temporary structures
there are other councils that actually
build temporary structures that are put
out people use them people hire to use
them and they're taken away if we did
that then we would have proper designs
of a temporary structure and I would say
that we should refuse it on lack of
planning information it is yes as you
said a temporary planning application
but there is not enough detail on this
plan to be passed I mean we've got
pictures of well there might be one put
here somewhere well whereabouts in the
amphitheater are we going to put this
temporary structure it's in that little
circle that is not enough detail
and that is what I would recommend
refusable
thank you thank you thank you
can you make it quick yeah the um the
broad plan that's in front of you
identifies the position of the
concessions within each of the red line
or with each of the seven sites so there
is a specific location within within
those red line areas that the Consortium
however Miss Matthews um if you look at
site B do you want to put the the
um these ones up on the on the board if
you look at site B that particular site
is actually on two levels
um are you putting uh or is the
applicant looking to put temporary
structures whatever those happen to be
in whatever design they are going to be
um no I don't want to look at those
thank you now
um
on the grass in the grass area which is
where they are currently
um are they going to be on the grass
slope are they going to be on the top
grass area or on the actual
um Half Moon bit at the top or on the
half moon at the bottom where the
pathway that goes straight through
um that's just one site we could then
look at site e which again is grass and
are we going to we're currently
um you know I think it's got hasn't got
anything on it apart from a a beacon are
we then going to be putting something
um
big small or indifferent on that
particular site that is then going to
influence or um be problematic for our
uh existing kiosks if we then look at
site D I'm not that familiar with it
um if it's in the play area
um there is no indication whether or not
the temporary structure there will be in
keeping with children's activities and
that sort of thing which would be
entirely reasonable would be entirely
reasonable
um there is a lack of cohesion with what
they with what the applicant wants to do
and the fear of members in my view is
that we are going to possibly have
popping up on four sites or or seven I
mean that's almost academic at one level
um things that they are not that are not
going to be complementary to either the
area that they are cited in
or to those that are going to be using
the part we have to protect the
environment which is a planning issue
what something looks like is a planning
issue and how it fits within the actual
environment that it is sitting Within
you could put a red bus on on party
that's temper structure for six months
we have no control at all over what we
are putting where
we also and one of the questions we
haven't asked is during the the um off
peak periods so between November and
March
um if it's uh if there's been a
temporary structure on a a g possibly F
and D
um
how are they going to be returned during
the Down Season to a usable state
because whenever you put temporary
structure on something
you will cause damage
you put a tent up
you put a car on a piece of grass for
six months you put a caravan on a piece
of grass for six months the grass
underneath dies
that's just
basic knowledge
um
so if that's true what what caused the
bill has said so I want to apologize to
Mr Johnson if I've put him in any
position that was unacceptable
um because
all I'm trying to do is to reach a
compromise so that we get the best
result for the park but I apologize on
record to Mr Johnson
councilor Lagan councilman that would
that would compromise
um I just wonder if a happy compromise
might be and people might disagree with
me is that we agree that the existing
concessions
should continue as they are in their
current locations
for one year
but no further concessions or no further
locations be considered without the
submission of a detailed Promenade Park
plan
that's all
second
okay I have a second uh can I have the
exact wording you're proposing Council
Tara
are you there Tara my memory is not that
good but
um
so that we that we are now that we we
approve the existing concessions
to continue the concessions so I'm
trying to do what you want we could own
it we're talking about planning so we
can only approve the excitement please
wait because
um councilman is making a proposal and
I'd like to hear what exactly what he
says before we move on uh when using the
work concessions uh say temporary
um uh structures
yes so um that we allow those existing
temporary structure concessions to
continue in their current locations or
their locations for a period of one year
but that no further structures or
concessions or locations be considered
until we have
a prom plan
or I'll I'll be even more flexible and
say or at least an interim prom plan
it isn't can you can you wait a moment
please um uh councilor Swain
um
well this is well this is
they're in these locations yes they're
in these locations they're our locations
this is as councilor Bill said this is
our application
from our offices from Malden District
Council we know where they are or at
least the officers know where they are
right well I mean all I can say is my
understanding that
um the the existing sites aren't exactly
no I I exactly consistent with what's
been proposed
so that really wouldn't be the app that
wouldn't be the application that we can
make a decision on that one's additional
well chair um I tried
um but you know as an example like as an
example I'd say the book the book um
modern books Shepherd's house that's
Shepherd's Heart where it is there
can continue for a year yeah that that
kind of thing that's an example yeah
the three concession sites you've got as
Council nun says within the red line is
B well that's that's currently where
Modern books has been located if you go
down to site f
which is opposite just past the splash
part before the um the the beach Huts
which is the little it cut out bit there
that's where currently the ice cream van
um
Charlie Moore is isn't it so that so the
proposal d d was where there was a
Structure wasn't there there was a
climbing frame thing maybe that's not
that's gone that's Curry there's none of
the others have got current concessions
on them so I would support what council
nun said about those three concessions
continuing for a year so that that would
be ABC
BCF sorry yeah
well none of that seems to apply to the
the council
surely what we're talking about is
agreeing that certain sites should be
continued to be used for concessions
with what the concessions are is a
completely it's not a planning matter
it's entirely what has been managed
but the design of those concessions is
is our business
um
and and how big they are the scale the
bulk
um whether they are
um uh the orientation the density I mean
you know all of those things do they not
apply to this application yeah but I
think council is hold on a moment I
could only have one person talking at a
time
Council Council Swain and then I'll come
to you councilor Lagoon
what you're saying is that that um the
officers would have to bring to the
planning committee every concession that
they envisage putting on every location
to see if we agree with what the design
of the object is
I was I mean it was referred to earlier
as being like an outline plan now to me
this isn't an outline plan
because you're actually asking us to
consider areas
and well there's something we'll go
there
so you then come back
to wanting something specific but that
won't come back to a planning committee
not normally
okay
but it can
we've done it before
so I'm just I'm just trying to use your
uh thought about trying to find a way
forward councilor Lagann I think
councilman's found the way forward I
think that if if we put the proposal
forward that those sites that we
mentioned are are supported through this
application and there's an amendment
that the other sites are not supported
and that it's a standard delegated
powers isn't it I can't ask you sorry no
no um it's under it's under it is
because I've learned this there's
significant delegated powers that
currently exist that allow decisions to
be made so if we gave the red light to
the sites and we said yes those three
sites can be used only and we you know
with the rest of council and unseconded
proposal
what we can then do is with him hand it
over to the officers to actually manage
those concessions for a year what they
are and what they'll be they may not be
the current people who were there
that's that's that can be dealt with
surely within this application for
design
that's what members are afraid of
we'll live permission after 12 months so
if they want to continue they'd have to
come back okay
councilman Dodge used to put into
clarification next time we have a
presentation about the prom can we make
sure we get the river right as well
oh
yeah it says the challenge
oh never mind it doesn't matter no
proposal so we have a proposal on the
table that we
um
approve
three of the sites I'm just making sure
so that is site B C and F
as currently
um
for one year
and that has been seconded by councilor
spensely is that correct counseling on
yes and then further submissions
subject to the
from plan or at least an interim program
did you get that Tara and I know and I
know that Mr Johnson might say that's
not a planning consideration but it's
our application
I just need to make sure Tara did you
get that
I would just like to go back because the
original proposal that was subjected is
different that doesn't refer to the
sites are you really referring to sites
referring to a plans oh yes we are
you are referring to I said it just need
to be sort of just literally clearer
sort of no no that's fine um the plan
that we're referring to is in the um
presentation plan and it is the site
photographs of the surveyed areas
yes it was yes yes yes
no no
okay thank you okay
um are you happy with the
um wording for the um approval
so we are saying hope we are proposing
that we approved besides bcnf as
outlined on the site photos of several
areas that were submitted yup for a
period of one year only yep
and you're then you're then you're
saying that no further structures
emotional locations be considered until
an interview from one o'clock plan has
been submitted uh yes I think yes that
is exactly yes that's it that's that's
perfect and that was seconded by Council
sorry councilor Spencer yes
there's nothing wrong with members
giving advisory comments here because
it's members advised that this at that
any future application be supported with
the with the management plan so I just
wanted to just draw that this
distinction I'm not saying that even if
I say it may not be a material planning
consideration in terms of the type of
application we're looking at there's
nothing stopping members from giving
their advisory comments and that'd be
minuted a grateful Church Mr Johnson for
his clarification thank you
um I would like just like to run through
the conditions that we have so that
everybody is absolutely clear
um restoration well obviously it's only
for one year and then the authority will
have to come back to um take that
forward
um everything is subject to and the
plans that have been submitted the hours
are Monday to Sunday
10 a.m till 10 p.m including bank
holidays April to October
and we've uh approved three sites B C
and F
um a refuse plan will need to be
submitted prior to any opening
protection of existing trees submitted
to Prior opening
I'll come back in just a moment
um flood warning and evacuation plan
submitted prior to opening
all enhancements and mitigation as per
the
um ecology letter statement of the 20 uh
of July 22 and that there should be a
biodiversity enhancement strategy prior
to opening
um detailing the designs that will be
used to mitigate
um Mr Johnson you also suggested that
um we should approve the designs before
they are
because members are concerned about
design the design aspect and that you
said that we could condition for that
yes we can condition for that okay so we
will also condition for that for the
design aspect as well
our members content with the conditions
councilor stilts
thank you madam chair I'm
surprised that we're going to let them
stay up until 10 o'clock at night
there's only the officers been in the
park at 10 o'clock at night
because are we putting in extra lighting
because it's yeah the the pound chance
that dusk
or whenever dusk is but the park if you
walk through there in the night is
really black and the lighting we've got
only lights the pathway so I just
wondered
um Miss Johnson Miss Matthews has that
been considered
and through chairman I did I did query
thee at the hours that I've been asked
for because as it was raised as um a
concern as part of the debate last
committee and
um again that these are maximums and
um the response I got is that they it
was not envisioned that there would be
concessions opening till 10 o'clock
um p.m regularly there might be the odd
odd day during the summer on us on a
Saturday night when when it's light till
that sort of time that they might they
might be there but it's not something
that is going to be consistent it was
just again to give flexibility
um so that that
um all interests in the park could be
considered and that it wouldn't be
um wouldn't have to be turned away
because of um some limitation
um but that there is in the same way as
we recommended three-year permission
then members are talking along the lines
of a temporary mission about that hour
the hours could be could be reduced it
could be limited to
um
Fridays and Saturdays I mean there's it
it could it could be reduced if that
that is concern
um but that but as officers we don't
think that there's a and that's
necessary but
um that is something within within your
power to to do as well thank you Mr
Johnson did you want to add anything
okay really worried about the worst it
wasn't envisaged and you know that we
don't feel I think we can't we can't
leave it that broad
sorry
did you disagree with that
I think what we've got to do is we've
got to say well
we need to be clearer to say yeah the
park has an open and a closing time so
the concessions are open from 10 o'clock
in the morning and until the closing
time of the park which in summer is
longer than it is in winter
and you don't need extra lighting put up
because as a member of the public the
antisocial behavior that will go on out
there would would be would be worrying
you know and I think it would be very
fair to The Operators to know the times
when they have the opportunities quite
flexible
why do we want to change it I mean if it
works and it gives the long hours in
summer because I bought to the committee
last time all of the sunset times so
we're given the opportunity to make
money while the sun shines but also to
have a surety and the safety in the
evenings when it's dark yeah
yeah until sunset is is a good good call
yeah I'm going to suggest that it it
needs to be a time that is um uh
nationally recognized if you like so yes
kids isn't it it's lighting up time it's
called lighting up time awesome can you
do 30 and 30 minutes before it does to
give him time to close down and then
leave
Sunset
um
um but it as long as long as it's a time
that can it talks about enforceability
of the condition so as long as there's a
time that is can be checked
um and uh can't be argued against
um then um and is clear then then yes
that could be I would suggest that 30
minutes before sunset
as per the
tables that you look up
there is there is National records of
daylight so Taylor time so we're just
going to that just seems safer and more
clear for the people and when we're
happy with that as the condition yeah
are there any other conditions that
members want to consider
councilor Swain
so we're basically approving this but
limiting the number we haven't voted on
it yet sorry we haven't voted but we
will no but in just a moment basically
the proposal has come down to approving
this in respect of certain sites correct
um and others then would remain on a
28-day basis correct
um right well the the two things that
two conditions that I wanted to suggest
was then that um well concessions may
not rely on Petra or diesel fuel
generators once in place
yep and the other is concessions shall
not use make use of electronically
reproduced so sound
or music if you like
is that enforceable
we have to make sure that it is
enforceable
um so I'm just I'm just trying to think
of the sort of conditions that
environmental health recommend on um
so I think they would refer to Amplified
sound
um
but we can um so no Amplified sound
yes
are you are you content with Amplified
sound no Amplified sound yes thank you
I beg your pardon
me no you can't no I know it isn't
um and no live music
because then we're getting into other
ground aren't we but it does depend
because live music is different for the
um
the concerts to where these concessions
I mean are you going to have live music
on these
question mark I'm just asking the
question
um councilor sorry Mr Johnson then I go
to council yeah it just sounds it sounds
like we're going into a different
scope of exactly of Proposal with what's
being put forward it's something that is
an opportunity to like throw everything
here and almost create a management plan
on the hoof well it just I just get the
feeling that that's sort of what's
happening I mean I'm content with what
we've got
um camp counselor bill
did you want to say something
after an hour and 21 minutes of debate
I'd like to know if councilor Swain's
I presume it's called objections to
policy N1 and N3 have been satisfied
I think so councilor Swain are you
content with uh yes that was purely to
enable the the motion to be called in
for discussion thank you Mr wasn't an
expression of my opinions okay okay I'm
going to draw the debate to close we
have a proposal we have agreed uh we
have a second up we now need to agree it
can I have a show of hands please
four five six seven
uh those against
and I shall abstain
so that's seven four one against and one
abstention
thank you members
um yes just just be 100 sure yes so
we've got the three existing sites BCF
yes for one year yes the the condition
we're asking for details of the design
of this concession before they
um are put in place yes
um opening times would be foreclosures
would be it'd be 10 a.m to 30 minutes
before sunset
um each day yes yep
um but then then there was discussion of
well the suggestion about no diesel
generators yes is that okay no Amplified
sound
yes and what about the live music was
that would really think that that was
going too far um
yes so this is why I wanted to clarify
to make sure that members were
sure about what they had voted on and so
yeah so so are we can are we content
with all of the conditions as well
as as it just literally just outlined by
yeah
oh no it wasn't no they weren't after
the vote they were before
councilor none my proposal didn't have
the conditions of The Proposal yes
um and I would think that the things
that Council Swain suggested would be
covered by our environmental health
officers yeah I think they are and I I
don't see them as necessary as
conditions
okay
counselor um trying to say
um there was much said about the um you
know the diesel or motor generators at
the last committee meeting so
um I definitely think that um that
should be a condition
I think there was was there not also
um they want them to be they're putting
electric for it was that just I think
And to clarify what was said about
electrics it was that the plan
permission like this would facilitate
the provision of electrics in the future
I don't think it was part of the
proposal or
um necessarily going to be put in but it
was it was it was mentioned that
um if if there was a permission that
would facilitate and may lead to the
installation of electrics at a later
date but um not as part not currently
okay and just as a procedural thing do
we have to vote on the conditions as
well yeah yeah okay so we've actually
got 10 11 12 conditions uh two of which
um have been proposed by
um councilor Swain I need to ask whether
or not members are going going to vote
for or against cancer still oh sorry but
we you have to actually put those two
extra conditions to be proposed seconded
and then we vote on
yeah what I was trying to do
um
yes so the two the the two extra
conditions are that
um diesel generators and
petrol generators are no longer
um to be used on site and that there is
to be no Amplified music on these
particular
music above 40 DBA or something like
that to give them a chance now they
might want to have a little bit of mood
music Charlie's art might want to have a
little kind of classical music you know
and also for having fun to the live
course string quartet they can get a
license from Sean Young and pay the fee
and then they can have it for a limited
time but I think saying no Amplified
music is so limiting
that I don't know just if we're trying
to create something here and trying to
be supportive and bringing people in
okay let's let's vote on it uh do I have
a second or first of all for the um
foreign
I've got a second I thank you can I have
a vote by hands all those in favor of
the two additional
um conditions
those against
one two three four five and I shall
abstain so that the vote uh I beg your
pardon
thank you
could we ask for a single condition no
no more conditions okay sorry I'm I'm
All conditioned out the vote there um
was um to to reject the two final uh
conditions
um and we will accept the conditions as
as they stand
thank you I'm gonna move on now
[Applause]
right
we now move to item six in your pack
application two two zero zero nine eight
three uh found on pages 33 241 The
Proposal is for an advertisement consent
in respect of a freestanding pole
mounted on a sign that will be
non-illuminated and for a temporary
period this is to regularize the
position of the cup of the existing
signage the applicant is Countryside
properties
um and this has come before us as a
result of a member call in
um from councilor Edwards who's not here
this evening I just you have somebody
missing
um
Miss Matthews could you
do your presentation please yes thank
you chairman uh so this is
um an application for a um an advert
and the current application relates to
the largest of the three sites allocated
for development in North haybridge
Garden suburb and in particular with one
of the three previously approved signs
to advertise the development
um of the garden suburb this sign is
located to the north of Langford Road
Northwest of the Cottages
well that helps
um deposit is retrospective in nature
and relates to the display of a v-shaped
freestanding non-elumerated sign located
on um 32 meters away from the
carriageway in Langford Road in
associating with the development
approved on-site
um with a 15419 out
so this is the plan that that
uh
that little red dot there is the
position of the sign proposed
it's close close the version of it with
these are the nearest Residential
Properties referred to
and these are elevations of the sign
that is there so we've got that one and
that one
um the rear of the sign and this is the
permission of the position of the
previously approved advert the same
advert but in a slightly positioned
position and this drawing at the top
there shows the position of the proposed
sign and the approved position of the
sign
and then we've got some photos of the
sign in situ
so the current applications will be
submitted to regularize the position the
sign and the same sign previously
approved
um in 2021 and the time was thereafter
installed 39 meters Northwest at the
consented location sign is visible from
Langford Road
um but it positioned further away from
from the
um further away from the road than the
previously approved sign and also
further away from the nearest
Residential Properties and therefore
would actually have a lesser visual
impact from public Advantage points and
having taken all considerations into
account it's found the current
authorized position assigned and does
not have a detrimental impact on the
visual immunity of the surrounding area
and in terms of Public Safety would
improve flat lines of vehicles using the
new roundabout at Langford Road
therefore subject to appropriate
conditions as recommended it is
considered that the application should
be approved thank you
thank you Miss Matthew is brilliant
um I was going to open it up councilor
spenceley and then councilor none hello
yeah could I just get some yeah sorry I
beg your pardon I didn't look
no no I can't
um sorry it's my understanding that the
speaker can't speak on this item no
that's it sorry
um so what I was going to ask
um because I'm probably being dense but
I just want to make sure that I've got
this absolutely right
um so can we
can I have assurance that if if this
would were approved would the
pre-existing approval still exist so
could we end up with because we're
saying this isn't an additional one but
then it's already approved isn't it so
at the other locations so I'm a bit
confused that so I just want to get some
clarity on that please
foreign
it's not my application so I've just
came here to present that I don't know
if there is a condition recommended
um but that is certainly something that
could be imposed so the developer has a
choice between the two but doesn't have
two just avoidance of any doubt
um it may not be possible legally anyway
but there wouldn't be any any harm
um bum break is possibly to put that
condition on yeah
to make sure that they only only get the
permission for the one
chairman this is it is a retrospective
thing the sign is there and it is yes it
is it is a retrospective yeah
yeah but they're looking to move the
sign
back
that's right it has been moved back
it's already been moved back it's it's
it was not put in the position in which
it was previously
all right okay yeah I think
but I think with cancer Spencer's point
was that in getting approval for this
they could effectively have two
permission permissions you know I get
that so that's nice that's the exactly
races
um to ensure that doesn't happen
um it's probably sensible
could I make one other point chair as
this yes of course councilman which is
that I have to note it here that the
wording of the sign is completely
ridiculous
because it isn't it isn't a new
community for Morden it's a new
community for heybridge and then
everybody here knows how strongly I feel
about that without me
um going on about it any further
um
what the wording on a sign isn't a
material consideration and certainly
nothing that could be
um required to be changed but the um I'm
sure if they're listening they've heard
it and taken on board and if any for the
film for the future
um
can I come to you after counseling on
please
happy chair to give away uh councilor
bail thank you Jay I'm just wondering if
uh myself councilor spencely and
councilor hoopner need to declare a
non-price prejudicial interests soon as
we're all members of North haybridge
liaison committee
so we do have meetings with the
management that is okay
um uh declaration be noted please Tara
yes please
sorry chairman each member would need to
make a declaration okay can I go through
uh councilor beale's done her
declaration councilor hubner yes
likewise for myself okay and councilor
Spencer yes I'm a member of the North
haybridge Garden suburb Community lies
and panel thank you
excellent thank you thank you that's a
good point though
um councilor none so I've been thrown
again on this one is this sign in a
consented location currently or not
no no so the consented location is
nearby
yes yes but this has been put in an area
where it hasn't had consent yes yes and
hence your point counselor spensely
about having two yeah potentially so
unfortunately this is retrospective
and again Mr Johnson might be saying to
me this is not a planning issue but I
reflect and wonder whether this is
really necessary
because actually it's confusing for me
given the location
because it almost kind of suggests that
where that sign is
there's going to be development
now that may or may not be the case I
don't know
um
is it not also as a we saw the scale of
it is this not visual clutter as you
enter the area along a
a main road
and is there not plenty of signage
already
advertising the development actually on
the site of the development
so I kind of reflect on this and ask
myself whether this is really necessary
thank you
and yeah councilor lagon
thank you probably didn't need to
declare an interest non-pecurity because
I have received an email from a resident
concerning
um concerns but some questions that were
raised which I think are very good
points I need to bring forward
um it talks about the government's
outdoor advertisements and science guide
says that when assessing immunity the
planet Authority must consider the local
characteristics of the neighborhood I.E
localities where they're important
Scenic historic architectural or
cultural features and we must need to
consider whether advertisement is in
scale and keep with these features given
that this is an area of Countryside and
close to three listed buildings this
advertisement is clearly not in keeping
with the local historic Scenic or
architectural features
with that actually would that apply
sorry tip three chairman
um I've just emphasized that the same
sign has got consent
40 meters to one side so
um in terms of reassessing its visual
impact
um I would suggest that that scope
doesn't exist because it's already been
done okay and it's already got consent
has already been grown sorry come back
here because it's 40 meters that's 120
feet and it's it's not two inches or six
foot it's quite a substantial distance
view in terms of its visual impact
um it's well in fact in our office
assessment is actually less
based on impact because it's further
than the houses and it's further away
from further away from the road so um
so um the officer thing was suggested
that would be a difficult stance to take
um but given the history so for example
if we refuse this they could just take
it all down and put it in the position
that it has already got plenty division
for yeah that's what we need to be
mindful of and and the permission would
only be for a temporary period so yeah I
think it's five years isn't it yeah in
terms of
um and that's that's actually from uh
five years from the condition of the
original application in 2021
I wrote it down
I did not didn't write down the date
though of the approval
um hold on a moment um I'll come back to
you councilor Spencer after councilor
Swain uh thank you Jim
um yes well we hope that the areas
the building is finished by then but it
could be um of Officer um confirm that
this is in fact the end the The Edge
near where the
um development finishes and the the Ring
Road actually will emerge
I I would add Madam chairman it's
unfortunate given that the sign is there
that we haven't got a picture of it uh
yes there is there is there is a future
there is a picture hold um welcome
yeah there's a picture that this bottom
one is the biggest one that you can see
um yeah so that's that's a picture of
the sign in situ so
um taken from the road so that's why
maybe it's hard to see because it's
quite a long way from the road
um but in terms of where it is in
relation to the development then
um this this the red line there is the
planning application the outline
information application it relates to
this this area here where the sign is is
where the um new vehicle access to the
site would be located so there wouldn't
be Housing Development
um next to where this sign is that will
be further further down the road if you
like but um that um
yeah it's part of the part of the
development albeit not the building side
of it it's part of the infrastructure
for that development yeah
and would be one of the main ways into
the development it's built
Council Spencer
so I just I thought this might be
helpful because I'm not great with maps
and and what have you which is not great
is it when you're sitting on a planning
committee but there you go
um so what I wanted
um in the conclusion which is on um page
36 at 3.2 we reference the um safety
aspect because we're the it says where
the sign would originally have been
placed would have been
simplified less safe so I just wondered
if we for the benefit of the committee
it'd be worth talking that through
because obviously if the site would be
removed from where it currently is to
where it was originally approved If This
Were refused and it wasn't so safe I'd
like well hey that's worrying that it
was approved in the first place in that
way to be honest but also I'd like to
just see what the difference is with
regard to the safety aspects because I'm
that that would help me out and I
thought it might help other people out
as well thank you Mr Johnson yes thank
you chairman
um
the
the previous application although
although the current application says
um this is in a better position in terms
of uh Public Safety yeah
um the previous application
um uh was supported by the highways
Authority
so in in in that application they said
they had no objection uh all proposed
signs are located on privately owned
land etc etc it's only unfortunate we
didn't receive a comment from the
highway Authorities on this application
uh but that was their comments on the
previous application
so
yeah come come back can I just come back
do you do we think that we need a
highways comment on this side because
I'm just thinking
um being that it has been moved and
we're saying it's safer but we haven't
had highways comment on it that that's a
little bit of a concern I did notice
earlier in the report that it does say
we don't have a comment from highways
but I mean I mean it's just trying to
understand exactly how the how it's
safer
um where it is is that because it's
further back from the roundabout and
therefore it I think in in respect of
car drivers it's therefore it looks
smaller okay because it's further away
okay well that's how that was how I read
read it yeah just yes exactly I mean the
thing is when we're considering
um
advert applications there are sort of
strict guidance around how you how you
assess it you know and it's basically
around public community and and highways
well Public Safety uh in terms of the
safety elements is is it going to be a
distractor to drivers I'm sure those of
us who drive are aware of what signage
can do to you
um hence this been uh or the emphasis in
the report that it's not illuminated so
it's not sort of providing that that
that
that sort of lit distraction that can
take your eye away from the road that
sort of stuff distance is also part of
it because it's not sort of in your face
although the other one was acceptable it
met the threshold this is an even better
location so for officers if we feel that
there's something we can mention that
will make a scheme even more attractive
not that the other one wasn't acceptable
in itself then we will just raise that
and that's what was said in this report
so was that the reason why it's been
moved was was that the driver or was it
the request of Countryside I'm just I'd
just like to
okay well I mean obviously while last
night and an issue for for the
consideration but but but we understand
it's something that operationally came
up as they're progressing on with the
development the position of the road and
the roundabout and that's all the stuff
yeah so those those are their
considerations as to why it was moved
it's just unfortunate they didn't come
to us beforehand before moving it yeah
okay
um any other counselor bill
foreign
I think we're just doing a paperwork
exercise here it's up there anyway but
I'm I'm pretty sure there's no houses
around there anyway it's most mostly the
bypass I think it is so it's it's
certainly requirements but at the end of
the day can we put a condition in to
actually
cancels out the previous planning
application for what was that where it
should have been
yes but for some stupid reason they put
it wherever
yes yes I have got I have got that was
covering the yeah okay do I have a
proposal from anybody
sir
you can't post it no I need a proposal
to either approve or reject this
application Council Council stilts well
I propose that we accept it but on the
conditioners councilor Bill said that we
put in a condition to say that this
cancels out the first
application that they received so they
cannot now build two of the do I have a
seconder cancel a Bill thank you
shall we take a vote all those in favor
could you show your hands one two three
four
five
all those against
thank you
um any abstentions
and myself
um that's carried
um
Tara that was six four won against and
two abstentions
thank you very much
thank you members I appreciate your time
um and thank you officers for your
contributions as well this evening
um the time is now 9 17 and I'm going to
close the meeting thank you